well i think it's so true what you're
saying we are seeing now that both
players are at the board i think it's so
true that when all our audience when you
see this match playing at the board
these two gentlemen over there
potkin the main coach and some of the
other coaches i think karjakin is pretty
clearly helping him
so all these things it is very important
for the player so when we see them
playing the opening it's actually not
only this fantastic two players playing
the opening but a huge team working for
them to give them the
the right advices so it means that they
have to have a great uh
a great feeling towards uh the trust in
their team so which is we are getting
the moves right now so young used the
same trick as magnus did he learned by
now that you can make a fake move first
and then correct it so he he did a fake
d4 but now he played e4 and we're
getting
the spanish
or at least the
let's see at least e4 e5 jan is still
thinking maybe the italian maybe the
score psychological waiting seconds
right
strange strange strange
maybe he wants to show magnus that he
can play the italian so repeat the
italian every day now
what about the scotch yeah the scotch
scotch is jan's favorite that is a 3d4
that's jan's favorite childhood weapon
but he has exhausted it by now he plays
i don't think magnus is falling into
this trick that the first move was
played by uh for the photo d4 and then
he put it back i don't think he fell
into that
but let's see how
we are
our prediction is doing quite well i'm
quite quite proud
uh i have all these moves already in the
lab viewer from from before
rookie one even yes b5 bishop e3 castle
now i predict a different land in h3 but
we'll see we'll see maybe he'll repeat
exactly the same line so let's see if
it's not h3 d3
yeah there are various options